امام الجيش الصيني الذي بات يمتلك اضخم
اسطول بحري في العالم وفي المكان الذي
يغيب فيه ظل امريكا تنين صيني بحري بقدره
صناعيه رهيبه تطورا اقلق الحلفاء والنيتو
لم ينجح في الامتداد الى المحيط الهادئ
بين الازمه والحل واشنطن لم تضيع الكثير
من الوقت ولد كبيرا في 2021 اوكوس حلف
بريطاني امريكي استرالي انضمامه واستراليا
رافقته قرارات صعبه راحه ضحيتها فرنسا
التي خسرت صفقه غواصات مع استراليا بقيمه
سبعه وثلاثين مليار دولار
وصلها وصفها بطعن في حليف
صفقه الغواصات التي تمت قبل ايام تلتزم
واشنطن بموجبها بالنقل تكنولوجيا نوويه
لبلد غير نووي هذا يحدث لاول مره في
التاريخ ورغم انها وصفت القرار بمجرد
تصدير طاقه نوويه الا انشاء بنيه تحتيه
مماثله في استراليا يقلق الصين مشكله اخرى
تؤرق بكين ما بات يجمع الثلاثي فقام مبادئ
من امريكا الى استراليا سيتم مشاركه
تكنولوجيا الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه والذكاء
الاصطناعي ووسائل الحرب الالكترونيه صدقه
غواصات تحولت الى بوادر سباق تسلح
استراليا ليست الوحيده المستفيده من
الصفقه
صفقه الغواصات النوويه التي ابرمتها
بريطانيا مع الولايات المتحده واستراليا
ضمن تحالف اوكس لن تكون في مصلحه استراليا
فقط حيث ستتيح الصفقه تحديد اسطول
بريطانيا من الغواصات النوويه ليصل الى
تسعه عشره غواصه بدلا من سبع غواصات حاليا
وسيشرع الاتفاق من الان في تدريب
الاستراليين على استخدام الغواصات وتطوير
قدراتهم البحريه على ان ترسل بريطانيا
غواصه واحده الى استراليا عام
2027 اما الغواصات الجديده التي ستكون
بتصميم بريطاني وتكنولوجيا الدفاعيه
امريكيه فسيبدا تطويرها اواخر هذا العقد
على ان تصنع بريطانيا اول غواصه اواخر
العقد الثالث من هذا القرن وتعد الصفقه
مكسبا سياسيا لسوناك الذي اثار حفيظه نواب
من حزبه بعد تحذيره في وقت صادق من خطط
الصين دون ان يصنفها على انها تهديد للامن
القومي